hey it's justine and i'm here at CES
2020 with BMW and today we're gonna be
finding out just what change your
perception means one of the things that
I'm so interested in is car tech the
future of cars is so amazing and we're
gonna see what BMW has here at CES this
year this crazy entryway is where BMW is
gonna be doing a top-secret reveal later
on and I'm going to be one of the first
people to get a chance to see what it is
which means you guys if you're watching
this you're gonna be the second people
to get a chance to see what it is I
guess let's just wait until the events
ready and I will get to show you behind
me is the BMW i3 urban suite this is a
concept car and we're gonna get a chance
to check this out it's street-legal it's
awesome
let's hop it the interior in this thing
is the first thing that you're gonna
notice it is modeled after boutique
hotels I mean it really does look like a
mini hotel on wheels everything about
this car was made with sustainability in
mind this leather was tanned with olive
tree extracts this oak is certified
sustainable even the carpet is made of
100% renewable materials this car was a
hundred percent assembled using wind
power and the carbon fiber was
manufactured using hydro power now let's
get into some more of these little comfy
features this really does feel like a
hotel and no hotel is complete without a
TV this is connected to Amazon you use
this little remote right here I can
watch TV
I can watch Amazon shows I can shop I
can watch Netflix I can watch YouTube
this is amazing and to go with the TV
down here with the cars I oh we have
this special port that will allow you to
mirror your phone we also have a USB C
and a USB a and of course a nice power
adapters I would get so much editing
done if this was my daily commute in Los
Angeles traffic you've got the plug to
plug things in and this is also equipped
with internet I'd be uploading YouTube
videos on the go okay bye-bye TV we've
got some more things to show them when I
first got in this car this is something
that caught my eye this is a little lamb
it is touch sensitive so I can turn this
on and off I mean the ambience
this is just so futuristic it's such a
simple detail but something about the
aesthetic is just so comforting and warm
and I feel like I could see myself
living here you can definitely tell by
the attention to detail is this isn't
something that they wanted to feel like
you're in a car it's more of a luxury
ride experience there's even a place to
hang up your coat there's a coat hanger
on the back of this chair nothing to see
here just my footrest I mean how many
cars do you know have a footrest that
can be controlled by these buttons right
here this is so cool and of course I'm
sure many of you guys were wondering
this because it's one of the first
things that I was wondering where do you
put the seat belt at it's like a normal
seat safety first there's something else
I need to show you
there are heated and cooling cupholders
so I've got my lovely iced coffee right
here
currently cooling and if Tyler up there
who's filming he might have a hot coffee
he can put his right there there's no
detail put up a huge fan one of things
that I love so much about this is yes it
is a concept there are a bunch of these
right now currently on the road it is a
completely street-legal vehicle there's
20 of them right now going around CES
and there's an app that people can
download and they can call one of the
cars and if there happens to be one in
the area they can pick them up they can
decide what they want the temperature of
the car to be what kind of drink they
would like to have ready for them in the
car and then it picks them up and it
takes them to their destination even
though this is a concept we already have
ride-sharing cars so why not take that
ride-sharing experience and elevate it
and make people more comfortable I'm
sure many of you guys have had some
ride-sharing experiences that are you
know maybe not the best but could you
imagine if you called a car and this is
what showed up there's even a personal
speaker in the headrest so when I'm
watching my movie only I'm really able
to hear it not the driver speaking of
drivers there's actually an autonomous
version of this where there's no driver
at all so let's go check that out
oh my drink oh my phone
[Music]
oh my goodness Oh hold on need to adjust
my footrest
sorry not ready to be doing an
autonomous drive here this thing is so
amazing like this is gonna change the
game especially for people who have long
commutes I could be editing an entire
video by the time I would get to Burbank
on the west side amazing so how do I
make it go okay we're about to take a
ride in the BMW i3 urban suite and this
is driving itself oh my gosh I didn't
get to finish my Instagram story no one
is driving this car right now this is so
awesome we're going through obstacles
and the car is driving itself is there
anybody in the driver's seat
negative it's so crazy because this is
the future like we're gonna be not
having drivers in the cars it's going to
be driven by a machine these are my feet
they are lounging change your perception
that is what I'm doing
wow that was amazing oh my gosh
yes I need one of these I had so much
fun checking out BMWs I three urban
suite right now we're gonna wait for the
event to set up and we'll head back here
tonight to see what it is the BMW is
gonna be revealing for all of us to see
here at CES
[Music]
we're back here where the press
conference is happening and we're gonna
get a chance to see what they're
releasing to the public before anybody
else so let's go see if we can sneak
around the back and get in
[Music]
Wow let's go check this out so this is
the BMW I interaction ease and I'm not
really sure what to expect so I'm just
gonna get in see what happens we need to
find out more about what this is
immediately where's Paul Paul what you
have behind you is our BMW I interaction
ease what this is is our vision of the
future of autonomous mobility looking
far out understanding when autonomous
mobility is more commonplace how do you
actually interact and understand and
enjoy that
[Music]
it's a concept of what it would be like
in the future when there's no steering
wheels what are you gonna do with all of
that free time when you're sitting in
traffic
BMW potentially has the answer to that
we're gonna do three key demos here
we're gonna explore entertain and ease
let's go check this thing out so awesome
looking they even have a couple over
this is very important where do I put my
coffee no way what is happening so
there's like a ton of LED lights ready
to begin our journey tap here so I tap
on the seat this is so cool okay that's
reacting right now to my gaze so I'm
gonna check this out we're gonna go to
the Aurora there's more at this loving
event you point out you will be in town
for the next concert if you would like
to go ironically I actually will be in
town on January 11th so I would like to
go there is still some time left until
your arrival would you like to watch the
video you started well yes of course I
would to adjust the volume simply wave
your hand left or right I'm adjusting
the volume with gestures so being able
to control this I'm using my gaze I'm
using gestures I'm using touch these are
buttons that I can interact with the
screen you can spend the rest of the
trip relaxing should I make the space
more comfortable for you yes I am
relaxing now no way if you tap again I
will put the seat up right what if I
want to stay here forever
fine
like this whole entire experience is
just that I've reached our destination
extinct I hope you enjoyed the
experience traveling with us I did you
soon I don't want to leave I'm so
excited about the future of mobility and
what BMW is doing to push this movement
forward
I am so here for it but I have to go
right now because now the rest of the
world gets to experience this
[Music]